foreign
[Music]
this week we have again prepared a
summary of the most exciting news from
Hollywood we discuss statements by James
Cameron on Avatar 3 the announced second
season of Wednesday and a potential
sequel to the horror film Megan which is
currently running in theaters we also
talk about a series adaptation of
Dungeons and Dragons the production
status of black panther 3 as well as the
Batman 2 and the first trailer for Fast
and Furious 10. have fun watching
just last week statements about a clash
between the conjuring doll Annabelle and
Megan did the rounds among those who
responded were horror icon Jason Blum
director James Wan and actress Alison
Williams according to them the
artificial intelligence Megan would
actually have a good chance against its
demonic counterpart well this week there
is also news about Megan as deadline
reports a sequel is already in the works
as a result of its successful U.S
theatrical release on January 6th James
Wan voiced great optimism to the trade
magazine highlighting the diversity of
the horror film which is both creepy and
emotionally moving at the same time he
also noted that the approach of
technologically driven horror rather
than supernatural horror is an important
feature of the film this sets it apart
from other genre Representatives he said
on Facebook Juan further wrote that he
and colleague Jason Bloom will hopefully
delve deeper into the world of
artificial intelligence and explore
Megan's Vengeance in a potential sequel
it can be assumed that the main Act
factors of the first part we'll be back
behind and in front of the camera though
an official confirmation is still
pending the horror movie was directed by
Gerard Johnstone while the story was
written by James Juan and akayla Cooper
Juan and Jason Blum were also in charge
of the production we look forward to
more news about Megan in the coming
weeks
hardly any other movie in recent years
has been the subject of so much
discussion about the lead character as
the Batman only few could imagine
Twilight actor Robert Pattinson in the
role of the Dark Knight he was still too
much associated with his part in the
fantasy Saga however the Blockbuster
which was independent of other DC films
was ultimately convincing and thrilled
millions of viewers worldwide ever since
cinemacon 2022 it's been clear that
director Matt Reeves is working on a
sequel but since then more specific info
hasn't been made public well that
changed this week as Reeves spoke to
collider last Wednesday about the
current production status after the
surprising decisions of the new DC
creative direction under James Gunn and
Peter Safran it was also suspected that
the Batman would be affected in some way
however that has since proven to be
false Reeves has confirmed that he and
his colleague Matson Tomlin who was
already involved in the Batman are
currently working on a film he did not
disclose which film is meant but his
statement at cinemacon and the
involvement of Tomlin suggest that it
must be the Batman 2. since the
production is therefore in a relatively
early stage a theatrical release before
2025 is not to be expected one thing is
clear however work on the sequel is
definitely in progress which means that
filming may start towards the end of the
year already in the future the Batman
Universe will be expanded further into
other directions with a series on Colin
Farrell's penguin being released for
example there are also plans for
spin-offs about the Arkham Asylum and
the Gotham City Police Department a
especially the series about the penguin
will be heavily linked to the Batman and
they even lay the groundwork for the
Batman 2 in terms of story unfortunately
there are no known release dates for the
spin-offs either
James Cameron's Avatar 2 the way of
water has been filling movie theaters
around the world for about a month now
more than 13 years after the release of
the first part the elaborately presented
underwater world and the almost
obligatory 3D experience Fascinate many
moviegoers and as far as Cameron is
concerned there will be no lack of
material for further releases in the
years to come the director spoke to the
French news site 20 minutes a few days
ago about the third part which is
scheduled for release in 2024 after the
oceanic Clan of the metcaina was
introduced in detail things will get
much more heated in the sequel Cameron
teased an appearance by the so-called
Ash people which will also bring overtly
evil mavi to the film series for the
first time the stark contrast between
almost entirely evil humans and almost
entirely good Navi will thus become much
more vague in the future which will
certainly benefit the plot's overall
depth whether and to what extent the
upcoming sequels Avatar 3 to Avatar 5
will be released depends largely on the
success of the current second part as
expected it was able to break the 1
billion US dollar Mark in the first two
weeks but in the best case scenario it
must bring in another billion to become
worthwhile for Disney Avatar 3 is
scheduled for release on December 20th
2024 and is currently in the
post-production phase
the Netflix series Wednesday is without
question one of the streaming services
major hits still it took a comparatively
long time before they officially
mentioned the sequel to The Horror
comedy in a press release Netflix
provided the information that the series
has been streamed 1.2 billion hours thus
far which makes it the third most
successful Netflix series overall
considering the numbers it was thus long
overdue to commission a sequel shortly
after the press release and the release
of a first teaser there were already
rumors regarding the plot of the second
season around the teenager Wednesday
Adams and her Supernatural Powers
Morticia Adams who is the matriarch of
The Adams Family is expected to play a
bigger role in the second season
according to the rumor Morticia will
assume the position of principal at
Nevermore Academy which would include
another part of the family of seven in
the series the end of the first season
certainly leaves plenty of plot for the
sequel however there were also negative
reports about the working conditions
behind the scenes after the release
leading actress Jenna Ortega was
critical of the external circumstances
of the production she was constantly
confused as how to proceed with her
character in addition it is said to have
been very exhausting to put herself in
the role of Wednesday Adams every time
both externally and internally moreover
she was suffering from severe symptoms
of illness in front of the camera which
is probably why Ortega was one of the
reasons that those responsible were only
able to announce the second season now
we are at least excited to find out
whether Wednesday season 2 can impress
once again a release date is not
available yet
many were taken by surprise when Black
Panther actress Leticia Wright
unexpectedly talked about a third part
in an interview during the pre-show at
the Golden Globes more than two months
after the release of black panther 2
wakanda forever Wright announced that
another sequel was already in the works
the cast and crew have had an intense
two years she added and will have to
take a break for now however she is
looking forward to the audience then
being able to watch the third
installment since Disney has not yet
spoken about another film the statement
comes more or less out of nowhere but
should of course please MCU fans
following her statement she still tried
to qualify what was said before but it
looks pretty much as though black
panther 3 is actually in the works
considering the success of the two
movies released so far black panther 3
seemed very likely anyway however as it
involved actress right now finally
buried all possible doubts we are eager
to see whether an official statement
from Disney or Marvel boss Kevin feige
will be made in the coming days and are
already up beat about the next news on
black panther 3.
during the last few days of the past
year we reported on a social media post
by Vin Diesel on this post he and his
fellow actress Jordana Brewster can be
seen but what was particularly
interesting was the caption it held out
the prospect of a trailer in the next
two months we already speculated in our
news that a spot at the Super Bowl is
very likely and as we have now found out
we weren't that wrong the movie magazine
collider exclusively reported that a
first three-minute trailer will be
released on February 10 2023 just before
the Super Bowl an additional clip will
be shown two days later at the biggest
TV event of the Year strictly speaking
you can look forward to two Fast and
Furious 10 videos within a very short
period of time the penultimate
installment of the nearly 22 year old
film series will then be released in
theaters on May 19 2023 and thus kick
off the grand finale of Fast and Furious
11. the franchise's familiar Stars will
be back including Vin Diesel Michelle
Rodriguez and Ludacris as well as the
newcomers Jason Momoa Rita Moreno and
Brie Larson
the pen and paper game Dungeons and
Dragons has inspired many generations of
enthusiastic fantasy role players all
over the world thanks to unlimited
creative possibilities players can
customize each playthrough according to
their own wishes which is what makes
Dungeons and Dragons so appealing on the
other hand there are considerably fewer
fans when it comes to the movies that
have been released so far particularly
the movie from 2001 has stuck in the
minds of fans and not in a good way the
reactions were all the more mixed when a
new feature film was first announced
many years ago in the meantime though
the hype can no longer be ignored which
is surely also due to the high profile
actors involved in the project as of
this week it has become known that it
won't stop at a feature film according
to deadline the film with Chris Pine and
Michelle Rodriguez is only the start of
a larger franchise Paramount is said to
be working with Hasbro's Production
Studio E1 on a live action series for
Dungeons and Dragons which will then be
released exclusively on Paramount plus
sadly there's no information yet on
whether the upcoming film and series
will be related in terms of story after
all there are theoretically thousands
upon thousands of ways to adapt the
role-playing game as a series the pilot
episode is directed and produced by Ross
and Marshall Thurber the red notice
director has also been working on a
movie adaptation of ubisoft's
third-person shooter the division since
2021 so he should be pretty busy at the
moment before that however we can look
forward to the Dungeons and Dragons
movie which is scheduled for release on
March 31st of this year
and that's it with our updates for this
week now you should be back up to date
if you're looking for more content check
out the new second trailer of Ant-Man
and the WASP quantumania we hope you're
as excited about the upcoming movies and
series as we are and that you enjoy our
next videos thanks for watching and
we'll see you next time
[Music]